philippe de clips bonjour bonjour le
ministre fait ce qu'ils veulent
aujourd'hui à parler d'engagement envers
les emplois da part d'airbus mais d'un
engagement verbal de garantie d'emploi
verbale ça veut dire quoi
parce que ça veut dire c'est que le
programme à 220 qui est le programme
essentiel de notre présence la présence
d'airbus au québec pas l'unique mais
l'essentiel est un programme en
croissance un programme sur lequel on
est en phase d'augmentation de cadence
et donc l'intention évidemment d'airbus
et de faire ce programme à succès et
donc de maintenir les emplois qui sont
autour de 7 de ce programme pour québec
donc l'intention c'est de maintenir
c'est en le voyant garanties verbales
pourquoi on ne va pas plus loin dans la
garantie d'emploi envers le québec parce
que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui ça sera
un peu
impossible de garantir quoi que ce soit
le monde le programme doit être
économiquement viable
si demain il ya un gros une grosse
récession économique une crise
importante ça nous amènera forcément
ajuster les productions donc voilà c'est
ce genre de choses
personne peut aujourd'hui garantir pour
pour toujours des emplois ce qu'on peut
enfin garantir c'est que l'intention
clairement n'est pas délocaliser c'est
pas de dire on va enlever la chaîne
d'assemblage de mirabel et la m je ne
sais où
la chaîne d'assemblage de mirabel reste
la chaîne d'assemblage est numéro 1 le
programme il est basé à mirabel
vous savez qu'on a aussi une ligne
d'assemblage aux états unis la vanne
alabama qui est ni nationale à côté de
notre île d'assemblage 3,20 mais la
ligne d'assemblage essentiel est numéro
1 reste à mirabel mais advenant cette
récession dont vous évoqué la
possibilité quand même d'ici 2026 ou en
tout cas dans les prochaines années
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir réduction
d'activité au québec
est ce qu'on pourrait faire le choix de
l'alabama plutôt qu'il du québec ne le
sait pas je pense qu'on peut pas se
poser vraiment la question dans ces
termes
toute société qui efface a fait face à
une situation économique à s'adapter à
la situation économique
voilà c'est simplement ça la chaîne
d'assemblage des us à mobile est fait
pour livrer les avions au marché
américain rick la chaîne d'assemblage de
mirabel est fait pour livrer les avions
au reste du monde
voilà donc c'est ça les équations et il
n'y a pas d'autres d'autres les juges
essaient de bien clair s'il ya un
ralentissement économique
il peut y avoir un ralentissement dans
vos activités ici disons qu'il peut y
avoir des suppressions d'emplois bien
sûr mais on n'est pas du tout dans cette
dynamique là aujourd'hui non la
dynamique aujourd'hui elle est plutôt on
est en début de 2
deux programmes on est encore vraiment
dans l'est dans les moments très
préliminaire du programme en est loin et
le début des livraisons la capacité de
production à mirabel elle est de 10
avions par mois
aujourd'hui on en est à quatre avions
par mois donc on tentera aller vers la
croissance pour arriver aux 10 avions
par mois donc on n'est pas du tout dans
une phase où on se dit on va faire de la
diva se rétracter et on est plutôt dans
une phase d'expansion aujourd'hui et
monsieur bolduc et la dernière fois
qu'on s'est parlé on avait évoqué la
possibilité d'un nouvel investissement à
mirabel
qu'en est il oui vous vous en souvenez
vous faites référence à ce qu'on appelle
la pré fall qui est donc qu'on a décidé
et consécutivement on va faire à mirabel
la pré fall c'est une activité d une
activité industrielle qui permet de
faire des travaux en amont de
l'assemblage et qui permet grâce à un
âge plus efficace ensuite donc oui on a
pris la décision de le faire d'investir
à mirabel a par ailleurs dû 15 alors on
va utiliser l'espace qui va être libéré
à la fin de l'année par par bombardier
et qui va arrêter sa production des crj
donc on va utiliser cet espace là pour
l'organiser et pour organiser la pré
fall qui devra être qu'il va être actif
qui commence on va le faire par étapes
et qui va pouvoir alimenter à la fois
les lignes d'assemblage de mirabel est
également la ligne d'assemblage de
mobile donc un glissement de combien
l'investissement je vais pas vous donner
de chiffres désolé les emplois
supplémentaires
c'est des emplois en tout cas qu'on
sécurise ses des emplois c'est de
l'activité qui restera à mirabel et qui
restera à mirabel encore une fois pour
alimenter les deux les deux lignes
pourquoi la valeur du programme à 220 à
baisser alors la valeur c'est une
c'est une chose très difficile à
quantifier parce que ça dépend de tout
un tas de paramètres paramètres de
valorisation qui peuvent aller des taux
de 10 42
des taux de change des hypothèses et
tout un tas d'hypothèses qui font la
valeur donc la valeur à un instant donné
et ce qu'allait on verra où elle sera
dans quelques années
aujourd'hui ce que je peux dire c'est
que le programme est en meilleure forme
on a commencé la réduction des coûts on
a on a eu des résultats sur la réduction
du coût sur les sur les derniers mois il
s'est pas assez il faut continuer on a
eu des succès commerciaux s'est pas
assez il faut continuer mais la valeur
baisser la valeur comptable abaissé
aujourd'hui en tout cas ce qu'elle telle
qu'elle est reflété dans la compte dans
les comptes de nos actionnaires
voilà on va voir comment ça évolue dans
le futur mais on doit pas s'inquiéter
parce que le gouvernement a vraiment
pris une provision importante par
rapport au centre je pense aux fins non
c'est pas c'est pas trop à moi de dire
je pense qu'on peut dans peut
s'inquiéter je pense pas qu'il faille
s'inquiéter sur la valeur aujourd'hui
moi je suis pas inquiet sur le futur du
programme quand une fois on est sur la
bonne trajectoire on est sur la bonne
la bonne dynamique aussi bien commercial
qu'industriel puisqu'on a quand même
entre 2017 et 2019 on a quasiment
tripler la production à mirabel on a
commencé la production à mobile et on va
commencer à livrer des avions cette
année donc on est vraiment dans la bonne
dans la bonne case voilà donc
aujourd'hui vous prenez un engagement
une obligation de racheter la part du
gouvernement du québec le 1er janvier
2026 pourquoi on vient fixer cela alors
ça c'est une question qu'il faut poser
aux actionnaires qui sont airbus et
airbus et les gouvernements je pense que
cette cette date
moi je ne suis que le que le président
de l'as du partenariat donc s'assurer
que le sable est vraiment une bonne
personne à qui vous posez cette question
donc d'en 2026 on aura donc sain 2025 on
aura une bonne vue je pense vraiment une
bonne vue de la situation du programme
on aura en ce sens devrait être dense et
en tout cas au milieu des décennies à
une cadence de production qui est une
cadence optimale 10 à 10 à mirabel et 4
et 4 à mobile on aura bien avancé sur la
réduction des coûts on aura aussi bien
avancé sur le succès commercial et sur
la et sur la partie vente et donc on
aura une bien bien meilleure vue de la
valeur justement dans vous parlez de la
delà de la société et lui faudrait y
avoir des appels de capitaux
supplémentaires au gouvernement du
québec taq s'est pas prévu du tout
aujourd'hui je te clair le programme à
220 dans le moment où il est a besoin de
financement c'est très clair il est
comme tous les programmes aéronautiques
qu'ils sont c'est à ce stade de la deûle
de vie c'est à dire on est au début de
la vie de production on a passé la vie
de développement on est rentré en est au
début de la vie de production c'est une
phase qui est très aussi qui est aussi
très consommatrice de capitaux
donc oui on a besoin de financement on y
est on a prévu d'aller chercher les
financements qui existent et qui sont
disponibles
encore une fois avec le succès qu'on a
commencé à montrer on doit pouvoir
chercher ce financement sans avoir à
demander de l'argent
au gouvernement du québec bien monsieur
bolduc rimoux merci beaucoup thuram
ainsi un plaisir de vous accueillir très
bien par voie